Hi, I'm Sebastian Thrun, and I've been
working on self-driving cars for
unbelievably long. My team won the DARPA
Grand Challenge. We came in second in the
urban challenge but I hired the people from
the urban challenge. I founded the Google
self-driving car team and I ran it
longer than anybody else. So I know a
thing or two about self-driving car. With this
new program you get a chance to learn
from the best people in the world all
the secrets about this amazing new
technology. We've put together a very
comprehensive introductory level program
on self-driving cars it should be
accessible to everybody. Why should you
take it? Well it's a fascinating
technology it's really amazing new stuff
and it empowers you to become quite an
expert yet but make a big step towards
becoming expert in self-driving cars so
please enroll.